welcome to Simply learn in this video we
will see most common types of cyber
attacks in the industry including
malware ransomware SQL injection fishing
and much more stick to the end of the
video to get detailed knowledge on cyber
attacks but before we begin consider
subscribing to Simply learn and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
us it's the year 2015 and Richard has
just finished playing games on his
computer after a long gaming session
Richard tries to shut it down but find
some random text file on the desktop
that says Ransom note the text file
mentioned how a hacking group had
encrypted Richard's game files in
private documents and he had to pay a
ransom of $500 worth of bitcoin in a
specified Bitcoin address Richard
quickly checked his files only to see
them being encrypted and unreadable this
is the story of how the Tesla Crypt
ransomware spread in 200 15 which
affected thousands of Gamers before
releasing the master key used for
encrypting the files so what is
ransomware for Richard to be targeted by
such an attack he must have installed
applications from untrusted sources or
clicked an unverified link both of them
can function as gateways for a
ransomware breach ransomware is a type
of malware that encrypts personal
information and documents while
demanding a ransom amount to decrypt
them this Ransom payment is mainly done
using cryptocurrency to ensure anonymity
but can also employ other routes once
the files are encrypted or locked behind
the password attack files available to
the victim explaining how to make the
ransom payment and unlock the files for
it just like Richard found the ransom
note text file on his desktop even after
the money has been paid there's no
guarantee that the hackers will send the
decryption key or unlock the files but
in certain sensitive situations victims
make the payment for hoping for the best
having never been introduced to
ransomware attacks before this gave
Richard an opportunity to learn more
about this and he began his research on
the topic the spread of ransomware
mostly starts with fishing attacks to
know more about fishing attacks click
the link in the button above users tend
to click on unknown links received via
emails and chat applications promising
rewards of some nature once clicked the
ransomware files installed on the system
that encrypts all the files or blocks
access to computer functions they can
also be spread via malware transmitted
via untrusted application installation
or even a compromised wireless network
another way to breach a system with
ransomware is by using the remote
desktop protocol or RDP access a
computer can be accessed remotely using
this protocol allowing a hacker to
install malicious software on the system
with the owner unaware of these
developments coming to the different
types of ransomware first we have Locker
ransomware which is a typee of malware
that blocks standard computer functions
from being accessed until the payment to
the hackers is complete it shows a log
screen that doesn't allow the victim to
use the computer for even basic purposes
another type is crypto ransomware which
encrypts the local files and documents
in the computers once the files are
encrypted finding the decryption key is
impossible unless the ransomware variant
is old and the keys are already
available on the internet scareware is
fake software that claims to have
detected a virus or other issue on your
computer and directs you to pay to
resolve the problem some types of
scareware lock the computer While others
simply flood the screen with popup
alerts without actually damaging files
to prevent getting affected by
ransomware Richard could have followed a
few steps to further enhance his
security one must always have backups of
their data cloud storage for backup is
easy but a physical backup in a hard
drive Drive is always recommended
keeping the system updated with the
latest security patches is always a good
idea apart from system updates one must
always have reputed antivirus software
installed many antivirus software like
kasperski and Bit Defender have
anti-ransomware features that
periodically check for encryption of
private documents when browsing the
internet a user must always check for
the lock SYM on the address bar which
signifies the presence of https protocol
for a additional security if a system is
infected with ransomware already there's
a website Noor ransom. org it has a
collection of decryption tools for most
well-known ransomware packages it can
also help decrypt specific encrypted
files if the list of anti-ransomware
tools didn't help the
victim malware is a malicious software
that is programmed to cause damage to a
computer system Network and Hardware
devices many malicious programs like
prion viruses bombs and Bots which cause
damage to the system are known as
malware most of the malware programs are
designed to steal information from the
targeted user or to steal money from the
Target by stealing sensitive
data let's take a look at the
introduction for two different types of
malware virus and
Trojan firstly let's take a look what
exactly is a virus
program a computer virus is a type of
malicious program that on execution
replicates itself they get attached to
different files and programs which are
termed as host programs by inserting
their code if the attachment succeeds
the targeted program is termed as
infected with a computer virus now let's
take a look at the Trojan hor Trojan
Horse program is a program that
disguises itself as a legitimate program
but harms a system on installation they
hide within the attachments and emails
then transfer from one one system to
another they create back doors into a
system to allow the cyper criminal to
steal our
information let's take a look how they
function after getting installed into
our
system firstly we have virus programs
the computer virus must contain two
parts to infect the system first is a
search routine which locates new files
and data that is to be infected by the
virus program and the second part is
known as the cop routine which is
necessary for the program to copy itself
into the targeted file which is located
by the search routine now let's take a
look at the Trojan Horse
functioning for troan horses entry way
into our system is through emails that
may look legitimate but may have unknown
attachments and when such files are
downloaded into the device the tro
program gets installed and infects the
system they also infect the system on
the execution of infected application or
the executable file and attacks the
system now that we understand what virus
and rions are let's understand different
types of virus
andran let's take a look at different
types of viruses the first one is known
as the boot sector virus this type of
virus damages the booting section of the
system by infecting the masterbot
recording which is also known as MBR
this damages the boot sector section by
targeting the hard disk of the
system then we have the macro virus
macro virus is a type of virus that gets
embedded into the document related data
and is executed when the file is open
they also are designed to replicate
themselves and infect the system on a
larger scale and lastly we have the
direct action
virus this type of virus gets attached
to executable files which on execution
activates the virus program and infects
the system once the infection of the
file is completed they exit the system
which is also the reason it is known as
a non-resident virus let's take a look
at different types of
troan the first type of troan is the
back door rosion they are designed to
create a back door in the system on
execution of an infected program they
provide remote access of a system to the
hacker this way the Cyber criminal can
steal a system data and may use it for
illegal activities next we have cric
sour Rion they enter the system by
clicking the random popups which we come
across on the internet they attemp the
user to give their personal details for
different transactions or
schemes which may provide remote access
of a system to the Cyber
criminal and the last troan type is
Ransom troan this type of troan program
after entering the system blocks the
user from accessing its own system and
also affects the system
functioning the Cyber criminal Demands a
ransom from the targeted user for the
removal of the Trojan program from the
device now that we understand some
details regarding viruses and troan
let's solve a
question the question is Jake was denied
access to his system and he wasn't able
to control the data and information in a
system now the actual question is what
could be the reason behind this system's
problem option a macrovirus option b
Ransom troan option C back Rion give
your answers in the comment
section now let's understand how to
detect the activity of viruses and
Trojan in our
system to detect virus or troan activity
in our system we can refer to the
following points for viruses we have
slowing down of the system and frequent
application freeze shows that the
infection of the virus is present in the
system then we have the viruses can also
steal sensitive data including passwords
Account Details which may lead to
unexpected log out from the accounts or
Corruption of the sensitive data and
lastly we have frequent system crashes
due to virus infection which damages the
operating system for Trojan we have
frequent system crashes and system also
faces slow reaction
time then we have there are more random
popups from the system which may
indicate prion activity and lastly we
have modification in the system
application and change of the desktop
appearance can be also due to the
infection of a Trojan
program next let's take a look at a
famous Cyber attack for virus and a
trojen
hor for virus we have the myom virus
which was identified in the year 2004
which affected over 50 million systems
by creating a network of sending spam
emails which was to gain back door
access into our
systems next for the troan horse we have
the emot troan program which is
specifically designed for financial
theft and for stealing Bank related
information next we have few points for
how to prevent virus entry or troan
attack for a
system the most basic way of virus
protection is to using antivirus and do
regular viruses can this will prevent
virus entry in the system and also
having more than one antivirus provides
birge better
protection then avoid visiting
uncertified websites can also prevent
virus entry into our
system then we have using regular driver
updates and system updates to prevent
virus entry for troan we have using
certified softwares from legal sites to
prevent any troan activity in our
system and also avoid clicking random
popups that we often see on the internet
and lastly using antivirus and Fireballs
for protection against troan horses is a
good
habit now that we have reached the end
of the video Let's Take a look what we
learned for the first part we saw the
main objective of the virus is to harm
the data and information in a system
whereas for the troan we have stealing
of the data files and information effect
of viruses is more drastic in comparison
to the Trojan
horses then we have viruses which are
non- remote programs whereas troan
horses are remote accessed and lastly
viruses have the ability to replicate
itself to harm multiple files whereas
strojan does not have the replication
ability so let's begin with what is SQL
injection as the name suggest SQL
injection vulnerability allows an
attacker to inject malicious input into
a SQL statement so SQL stands for
structured query language which is a
language used by an application to
interact with the database now normally
this attack is targeted towards a
database to extract uh the data that is
stored within however the vulnerability
does not lie in the database itself the
vulnerability will always lie in the
application it is the developers
prerogative of how to develop the
application how to configure it to
prevent seel injection queries from
happening a database is created to
answer questions and if a question is
asked it is supposed to answer it
database needs to be configured for some
amount of security but the vulnerability
the flaw here for SQL injection will
always lie in the application itself it
is how the application interacts with
the database that means needs to be
modified that needs to be maintained by
the developer rather than just
configuring the database itself so the
attacker at this point in time when they
send a query to the application will
form a malformed query by injecting a
particular command or an operator that
is recognized by the SQL language and if
that operator is passed through the
application to the database then the
database basically gets cracked or does
a data dump because of that unwanted
character coming in so this character
needs to be filtered at the application
Level itself now let's look at a quick
demo so what we have done here is I have
this virtual machine called oasp broken
web applications virtual machine version
1.2 I'm going to power this
on till this power is on I'm going to
show you where we can download this uh
utility from so you can just look for
OAS broken web application project
download you'll find it on
sourceforge.net click on the
link you can download the broken web
application project from here this is a
1.9gb download and you can have a zip
machine directly for VMware or Oracle
virtual box now this is an application
that has been developed by oasp which
stands for open web application security
project which is a not for profit
organization and and uh periodically
releases the most top 10 risks that an
application uh will face for that
particular
year so they have given a web
application uh with inbuilt
vulnerabilities for professionals like
us to practice upon to develop our
skills upon because doing this in the
real world is illegal I cannot go on to
a website to demonstrate how a SQL
injection attack Works uh neither should
you try your your hands on it till you
become very well rehearsed with it so
till to upgrade your skills to upskill
yourself please download this machine
hosted in a VM workstation or Oracle
virtual box and you can uh then try your
skills on it right so just going back to
the browser here if I open up uh a new
tab you'll see that this machine has
booted up and has an IP address called
7113 to so if I just go on to that IP
address and I type in 192
132 and you'll see the oasp broken web
application project and there are lot of
training applications realistic
intentionally vulnerable applications
old versions of real applications and so
on so forth so there is a lot of
applications in built over here that you
can try your skills upon we are going to
try to use the OAS mutil day over here
uh this gives you the uh OAS top 10
risks for 2010 20133 2017 is the latest
one so far uh but the difference between
2013 and 2017 is that some of these have
changed but not all of them uh the order
has changed a little bit but you can see
that SQL injection is on the top A1
amongst the injection attacks right and
you can see there are multiple types
that have been given here the SQL
injection for extracting data or SQL
injection for bypass authentication or
insert your injection uh uh attacks
blind SQL injection and then there is a
tool called SQL map which is available
freely on your Linux machines Ki Linux
or parot Linux whichever you want to use
uh for your practice targets and so on
so forth so if I just take you here for
bypass
authentication and this is a regular
login page that an application may have
right you look at a username you look at
password you type that in and you log in
so let's say I don't know a password
here I'm just going to type in the
username test password is pssw Rd I try
to log in and it shows me that the
account does not exist so the
authentication mechanism does work the I
did try type in a username and password
it wasn't recognized so the account does
not exist now let's try to type in a SQL
query here I'm going to just give it a
single quote which is an operator that
is recognized by the SQL language which
when the database tries to execute uh
will cause the database to uh dump some
data or to bypass authentication in this
case and I'm going to give it a
condition single
quote or 1 equals 1 space hyphen hyphen
space and I'm going to click on login
now right now I'm not logged in at all
and we tried our username and password
and we weren't able to log in so now if
I log in you will see that it give me a
status update saying the user has been
authenticated and I'm Lo loged in as
admin got root so that is what these SQL
queries can achieve I'm going to log out
right now and uh we're going to look at
the basics of SQL injection so looking
at that small demo looking now let's
look at what types of SQL injections are
available so the first is inband SQL
injection the there are two subtypes
within inband error based injection
attack and a union based injection
attack the second type is blind SQL
injection attack where there's a Boolean
based and a Time based attack and the
third one is outof bound SQL injection
attack now what is inband SQL injection
attack in band is where we either
attempting the error based or the union
based what is error based uh we send a
query to the database we craft a query
to the database and uh it generates an
error M message and it dumps the error
message right in front of us on the
screen that makes us realize that that
there is a flaw and there there is some
information that is dumped on the screen
which we can then further utilize to
craft our further queries as we go ahead
whereas Union base is the it is where we
combine multiple statements at the same
time so if you look at the URL earlier
in the URL you would see a large
structure in that URL uh we can try to
add more two or more statements within
the URL itself to combine them and then
confuse the database into executing both
the statements together and giving a
data dump at the same time right so what
would the error based uh SQL injection
look like if I go back to the same
database uh which is here right and if
you remember the user name we give it a
single quote r 1 equals 1 space hyphen
hyphen space we gave it the condition
right so basically what it did was this
a single code is an operator that goes
to the database selects the D default uh
table uh in the user tables in this
database column and then Compares it to
the condition that is given so the
condition that we gave was 1 equals 1
which is always true so what it did was
it selected the default uh user table
that was available in the database and
instead of comparing it to a password it
compared it to the condition so if I
give it 1 equals 2 where the condition
is false and if I log in you will see
that the doesn't exist comes back again
because the condition was false and
instead of comparing the user account to
the password it basically uh compared
the user account to the condition so if
I give it a single quote or 1 equals 1
hyphen hyen space uh and log in you can
see that this is a correct condition and
thus we are able to log in now before we
even go to that extent if I just forget
the condition over here and I just give
it a single quote the operator and I
send this operator to the database and I
click on login you will see that it
generates an error which is right on top
and it tells us the line the uh file
where the error happened and you can see
it happened in the MySQL handler. PHP
file right and then it give us the
message you have an error in your SQL
syntax check the manual that corresponds
to your MySQL server version for the
right syntax to use now why would a
hacker want to do this in the first
place because there are different types
of data bases so there is a MySQL Ms SQL
or Microsoft SQL Oracle SQL IBM db2 all
of these are variations of the SQL
database uh they use the SQL language
however every database has its own
Command right they they have their own
syntax they have their own uh specific
commands that are utilized for the
database so in this scenario the hacker
wants to identify what database is being
currently utilized so they can craft
those particular ular queries so now
with this injection with just me sending
the quote and the error getting
generated I now come to know that we are
using a MySQL server and the version of
that server is 5.1.7 3 and uh the rest
of the information about uh where the
handlers are located and so on so forth
right this gives the information to the
hacker of how they want to proceed next
what kind of queries they want to create
what kind of syntax they want to utilize
so error based attack is where you
generate these kind of Errors uh and you
get this information the union base is
where you craft your queries within the
URL or you can try to combine multiple
statements within the input fields and
try to generate a response from that
then we come to Boolean based SQL
injection uh sends a SQL query to the
database which forces the application to
return a different result depending on
whether the query returns a true or a
false result so basically if the input
is false the input both the inputs are
false the output would be false uh
there's one input that is false other
input that is true input B the output
would be true and so on so forth right
so depending on the result from the
inputs the attackable will come to know
which input is true with this he can
then access the database of the website
so you're trying to figure out by
sending out multiple inputs uh and then
analyzing the output to see what exactly
uh which command exactly worked what was
the resultant output of that command
thus from this kind of an information
the hacker can infer their next step
forward then you have timebase SQL
injections uh now there are times when a
database administrator and application
administrator has done some security
configuration and does have disabled
verbos error messages now what is a
verbos error message the error message
that we saw right here is a verbos error
message that means that the message
gives out details the message gives out
details about what the database is the
version and whatnot so if they have
sanitized these
errors and you no longer can generate
these errors and thus you cannot figure
out what database is then what do you do
right for example if I just take you to
Simply
learn and
take you to a URL that is supposedly not
accessible you can see that it gives a
generic error oops like it looks like
you crash landed on Mars it doesn't give
you a verbos error that we saw here so
this gives us a detail ER of what went
wrong where it gives us the database the
version of the database and uh where the
query went wrong and etc etc etc whereas
on this s where there's some there's a
lot of security that goes in here so you
can see that it doesn't generate a error
it just get a generic page in front of
you so in that case what does a hacker
do so the hacker then injects a Time
based uh query in the URL which allows
us to verify whether the command is
being executed or not so uh we put in a
time
weit let's say 10 seconds of time weit
so if we the moment we inject the query
if the query times for 10 seconds and
then gets executed that means that the
SQL injection is possible however if we
inject the query and uh it just gets
executed without the delay that means
that the time uh injection attack would
not be uh possible on that particular
side out of account is not a very common
attack it depends on the features being
enabled on the database management
system that is being used by the web
application so this can be a somewhat of
a misconfiguration error uh by the
database administrator where you have
enabled functions and not sanitize them
so you have not done in access controls
properly you have not given account
control so queries should never be
executed at an administrative level they
should always be uh executed user level
with minimum privileges that are
required for that query to be executed
now if you're allowing these kind of
functions to be uh to be enabled at the
dbms and there is an administrative
account that can have access to them at
that point in time an outof bound
injection attack is possible so let's
look at how a website works right uh how
SQL works on a website now the website
is constructed of HTML hypertext markup
language uh which would include Java
javascripting for functionality
cascading stylesheets for the mapping of
the website right and then reactjs and
whatnot uh for further functionality now
when we send a query to the website it
is normally using the HTTP protocol or
https protocol when the query reaches
the application the application would
then go ahead and generate the SQL query
uh at the client side you'll have uh all
these scripting languages coming in uh
on the front end uh that we can utilize
to craft queries and then send them
across at the server side you'll have uh
databases like Oracle MySQL Ms SQL and
so on so forth that will then execute
those queries right so just to give you
an example if I use a tool called
Postman what we generally do uh when we
craft a query is we send out a uh get
request to the website and then we
receive a response from the site uh with
the HTML code and everything so this is
a tool that is utilized by software
testers to test the responses that
you're going to get from various
websites so on the left hand side you
can see I've uh used it on quite a bit
uh here we have a example for gmail.com
so let's continue with that so this is a
get request being sent to Gmail the
moment I send it it's going to create an
HTTP request and send it across the
response that I get is this this is the
HTML code for
gmail.com right these are the cookies uh
these are the headers uh that include
information so you can see this is a
text HTML character set utilized is
udf8 and the configuration uh that has
been done with the application right so
this is where uh everything comes in
this is the cookie that has been sent
with that particular uh request that I
had sent out now if you Analyze This
query right so when we went onto this
application and I typed in that single
quote and we generated this error
right uh you can see that the
application converted this into a SQL
query so the query was select username
from accounts where the username in
quote single quotes and we use the quote
right the single quote right there so uh
that's where we use that operator and
that's where the exception error
occurred so these are the kind of
queries that are structured by the
application and then taken on to the
database for execution when we type in
uh it it is a HTTP get request with the
username and password within that query
uh that is sent to the application the
application converts it into a SQL query
sends it to the database and the
database responds with the appropriate
response so how do we prevent SQL
injection in the first place use
prepared statement and parameterized
queries uh these statements make sure
that the parameters passed into SQL
statements are treated in a safe manner
so for example we saw that the single
code was an operator this shouldn't be
allowed to be utilized in the first
place right so here what we are doing
here is a secure way of running a SQL
query in the jdbc using a parameterized
statement Define which user we want to
find so there's a string the email comes
in connection to the database we are
going to figure out how the connection
is going to be passed how it is going to
be created construct the SQL statement
we want to run specifying the parameter
right so we Define how is it going to be
uh created what is going to be created
what can be pass to the database and
what should not be passed to the
database so that is one way of utilizing
prepared statements and parameterized
queries then we have object relational
mapping most development uh teams prefer
to use object object relational mapping
Frameworks to make the translation of
SQL results set into code objects more
seamless so this is an example of object
relational mapping uh where we map
certain objects and allow that to be
executed
and then escaping inputs it a simple way
to protect against most SQL injection
attacks many languages have standard
functions to achieve this right so you
need to be very careful while using
Escape characters in your code base when
a SQL statement is constructed not all
injection attacks rely on abuse of quote
characters so you need to know what
characters are being utilized uh in the
configuration that you have created in
the structure that you have created in
the code that you have created uh which
characters are being recognized as
operators you need to sanitize those
operators and you need to uh basically
ensure that these operators cannot be
accepted as user input if they are they
feed out by the application and they
never reach the database other methods
of uh preventing SQL injection are uh
password hashing so that passwords
cannot be bypassed the passwords cannot
be recovered passwords cannot be cracked
uh third party authentication you use o
or uh some other service for a single
sign on mechanism does uh you rely on a
third party to maintain the security of
authentication and uh what kind of
parameters are passed for example uh
using LinkedIn logins or Facebook logins
right uh for the Layman you normally go
on to Facebook and you allow if you're
using a game right if you start playing
a game you're allowed to log into the
game using your Facebook credentials or
your Google credentials now that is not
just for ease of use but the game user
the developer has outsourced the
authentication mechanisms to third party
such as Facebook or Google because they
understand that that authentication
mechanism is as safe as can be Facebook
and Google are wealthy organizations uh
hire a lot of Security Experts and the
development for their authentication
mechanisms is topnotch the small
organization cannot spend that kind of
money on security itself right so you
use a third party authentication
mechanism to ensure that these kind of
attacks may not happen then web
application firewalls uh having a web
application firewall and configuring it
properly uh for SQL injection attacks is
one of the Sure Shot method of uh
mitigating or minimizing the uh threat
in the first place so at this point in
time you have realized that the
application has some V abilities for SQL
injection and instead of recoding or
restructuring the application uh you
want to take the easier way out or the
cheaper way out so what you do is you
you install a web application firewall
and you configure the web application
firewall to identify malicious queries
and stop them uh at the firewall level
itself so they never reach the
application and thus the vulnerabilities
on the application don't get
executed buy better
software and keep on updating the
software so it's not necessary that once
you have a software you install it it's
going to be safe for life new V
abilities are discovered every day every
hour and it may so happen what is
secured today may be completely insecure
tomorrow or the day after right so you
need to keep on upgrading the software
if there are no upgrades available and
the vulnerability still exist you might
want to migrate to a better software and
does uh ensure that you don't get hacked
right always update and use patches
organizations keep on sending out
updates and patches as and when they are
released you need to install them to uh
enhance your security postures and then
continuously monitor SQL statements and
databases use protocol monitors uh use
different softwares use the firewalls to
keep on monitoring what kind of queries
you're uh getting and based on those
queries you want to ensure the inputs
and the queries that are creating uh are
not detrimental to the health of the
software that you have Jane is relaxing
at home when she receives an email from
a bank that asks her to update her
credit card pin in the next 24 hours as
a security measure judging the severity
of the message Jane follows the link
provided in the email on delivering her
current credit card pin and the
supposedly updated one the website
became unresponsive which prompted her
to try sometime later however after a
couple of hours she noticed a
significant purchase from a random
website on that same credit card which
she never authorized frantically
contacting the bank Jane realized the
original email was a counterfeit or a
fake message with a malicious link that
entailed credit card fraud this is a
classic example of a fishing attack
fishing attacks are a type of social
engineering where a fraudulent message
is sent to a Target on the premise of
arriving from a trusted Source its basic
purpose is to trick the victim into
revealing sensitive information like
passwords and payment information it's
based on the word fishing which works on
the concept of baits if if a supposed
victim catches the bait the attack can
go ahead which in our case makes Jane
the fish and the fishing emails the bait
if Jane never opened the malicious link
or was cautious about the email
authenticity an attack of this nature
would have been relatively
ineffective but how does the hacker gain
access to these credentials a fishing
attack starts with a fraudulent message
which can be transmitted via email or
chat applications even using SMS
conversation to impersonate legitimate
sources is known as smishing which is a
specific category of fishing attacks
irrespective of the manner of
transmission the message targets the
victim in a way that coaxes them to open
a malicious link and provide critical
information on the requisite website
more often than not the websites are
designed to look as authentic as
possible once the victim submit
information using the link be it a
password or credit card details the data
is sent to the hacker who designed the
email and the fake website giving him
complete control over the account whose
password was just provided often carried
out in campaigns where an identical
fishing mail is sent to thousands of
users the rate of success is relatively
low but never zero between 2013 and 2015
corporate giants like Facebook and
Google were tricked off of 100 million
due to an extensive fishing campaign
where a known common associate was
impersonated by the hackers apart from
credit access some of these campaigns
Target the victim device and install
malware when clicked on the malicious
links which can later function as a botn
net or a target for ransomware attacks
there is no single formula for there are
multiple categories of fishing attacks
the issue with Jane or the hacker stoer
Bank credentials falls under the
umbrella of deceptive fishing a general
email is sent out to thousands of users
in this category hoping some of them
fall prey to this scam
spear fishing on the other hand is a bit
customized version the targets are
researched before being sent an email
for example if you never had a Netflix
subscription sending you an email that
seems like the Netflix Team sends it
becomes pointless this is a potential
drawback of deceptive fishing techniques
on the other hand a simple screenshot of
a Spotify playlist being shared on
social media indicates a probable point
of entry the hacker can send counterfeit
messages to the Target user while
implying the source of such messages
being Spotify tricking them into sharing
private information since the hacker
already knows the target use of Spotify
the chances of victims taking the bait
increase substantially for more
important targets like CEOs and people
with a fortune on their back the
research done is 10 full which can be
called a case of wailing the hackers
prepare and wait for the right moment to
launch their fishing attack often to
steal industry secrets for rival
companies or sell them off at a higher
price apart from just emails farming
focuses on fake websites that resemble
their original counterparts as much as
possible a prevalent method is to use
domain names like Facebook with a single
o or YouTube with no e these are
mistakes that people make when typing
the full URL in the browser leading them
straight to a counterfeit web page which
can fool them into submitting private
data a few more complex methods exist to
drive people onto fake websites like ARP
spoofing and DNA N Cash poisoning but
they are rarely carried out due to time
and resource constraints now that we
know how fishing attacks work let's look
at ways to prevent ourselves from
becoming victims while the implications
of a fishing attack can be extreme
protecting yourself against these is
relatively straightforward Jane could
have saved herself from credit card
fraud had she checked the link in the
email for authenticity and that it
redirected to a secure website that runs
on the https protocol even susp
supicious messages shouldn't be
entertained one must also refrain from
entering private information on random
websites or pop-up Windows irrespective
of how legitimate they seem it is also
recommended to use secure anti-fishing
browser extensions like cloudfish to
sniff out malicious emails from
legitimate ones the best way to prevent
fishing is browsing the internet with
care and being on alert for malicious
attempts at all times start by learning
about cross-site scripting from a
Layman's
perspective
cross-site scripting also known as xss
is a type of code injection attack that
occurs on the client side the attacker
intends to run harmful scripts in the
victim's web browser by embedding
malicious code in a genuine web page or
online application the real Attack takes
place when the victim hits the malicious
code infected web page or online
application the web page or application
serves as a vehicle for the malicious
script to be sent to the users's browser
forums message boards and online pages
that enable comments are vulnerable
vehicles that are frequently utilized
for cross scripting
assaults a web page or web application
is vulnerable to xss if the output it
creates contains unsanitized user input
the victim's browser must then par this
user input in VB script ActiveX Flash
and even CSS cross-side scripting
attacks are conceivable they are
nevertheless most ubiquitous in
JavaScript w to the fact that JavaScript
is most important to most browser
experiences
nowadays the main purpose of this attack
is to steal the other users identity be
it via cookies session tokens and other
information in most of the cases this
attack is being used to steal the other
person's cookies as we know cookies help
us to log in automatically therefore
with the stolen cookies we can log in
with other identities and this is one of
the reasons why this attack is
considered as one of the risky attacks
it can be performed with different
client side programming languages as
well cross-site scripting is often
compared with similar client side
attacks as client side languages are
mostly being used during this however an
xss attack is considered riskier because
of its ability to damage even less
vulnerable
Technologies most often this attack is
performed with JavaScript and HTML
JavaScript is a programming language
that runs on web pages inside your
browser the client site code add
functionality and interactivity to the
web page and is used extensively on all
major applications and CMS platforms
unlike serers side languages such as PHP
JavaScript code runs inside your browser
and cannot impact the website for other
visitors it is sandboxed to your own
Navigator and can only perform actions
within your own browser window while
JavaScript is client side and does not
run on the server it can be used to
interact with the server by performing
background requests attackers can then
use these background requests to add
unwanted spam content to a web page
without refreshing it they can then
gather analytics about the client's
browser or perform actions
asynchronously the manner of attack can
range in a variety of ways it can be a
single link which the user must click on
to initiate a JavaScript piece of code
it can be used to show any piece of
images that can be later used as a front
end for malicious code being installed
as malware with the majority of Internet
users unaware of how metadata works or
the ways in which web requests are
called the chances of victims clicking
on a redirecting links is far too high
cross-side scripting can occur on the
malicious script executed at the
client's side using a fake page or even
a form that is displayed to the user on
websites with displayed advertisements
malicious emails can also be sent to the
victim these attacks occur when the
malicious user finds the vulnerable
parts of the website and send it as
appropriate malicious
input now that we understand the basics
of cross-site scripting let us learn
more about how this kind of attack
works in the first place we have the
website or the web browser which is used
to show content to the victim or which
is the user in our case whenever the
user wants to grab some content from the
website the website asks the data from
the server the server provides this
information to the website and the web
browser which ultimately resist the
victim
how the hacker comes into play here it
passes on certain arguments to the web
browser which is can be then forwarded
back to the server or to the user at
hand the entire cross-site scripting
attack Vector means sending and
injecting malicious code or script this
attack can be performed in different
ways depending on the type of attack the
malicious script may be reflected on the
victim's browser or stored in the
database and executed every time when
the user calls the appropriate function
the main reason for this attack is
inappropriate users input validation
where the malicious input can get into
the output a malicious user can enter a
script which will be injected onto the
website's code then the browser is not
able to know if the executed code is
malicious or not therefore this
malicious script is being executed on
the victim's browser or any faked form
if that is being displayed for the users
there are many ways to trigger an xss
attack for example the execution could
be triggered automatically when the page
loads or when a user hovers over
specific elements of the page like
hyperlinks potential consequences of
cross-site scripting attacks include
capturing keystrokes of a user
redirecting a user to malicious websites
running web browser based exploits
obtaining cookie information of a user
who is logged into a website and many
more in some cases cross-side scripting
attack leads to complete compromise of
the victim's account attackers can trick
users into entering credentials on a
fake form which can then provide all
information to the attacker with the
basic working of a cross-side scripting
attack out of the way let us go over the
different ways hackers can leverage
vulnerable web applications to gather
information and eventually breach those
systems the prime purpose of Performing
xss attack is to steal the other
person's identity as mentioned it may be
cookies session tokens
Etc xss may also be used to display
faked Pages or forms for the victim
however this can be performed in several
ways we have a reflected attack this
attack occurs when a malicious script is
not being saved on the web server but is
reflected in the website results
reflected accss code is not being saved
permanently in this case the malicious
code is being reflected in any website
result the attack code can be included
in the faked URL or in the HTTP
parameters it can can affect the victim
in different ways by displaying fake
malicious page or by sending a malicious
email in a reflected cross-side
scripting example the input of a search
form is reflected on the page to show
what the search key was an attacker May
craft a URL that contains malicious code
and then spread the same URL via email
or social media a user who clicks on
this link opens the valid web
application which then runs the
malicious code in the browser this
script is not stored in the web
application and malicious code is shown
only to one user the user that opens the
link executes the script and the attack
is not necessarily visible on the server
side or to the app owner
itself the next variant is a stored
cross-side scripting
attacks this occurs when a malicious
script is being saved on the web server
permanently this can be considered a
riskier attack since it has leverage for
more damage in this type of attack the
malicious code or script is being saved
on the ser server for example in the
database of the website it is executed
every time the users call the
appropriate
functionality this way stored xss attack
can affect many users also as the script
is being stored on the web server it
will affect the website for a longer
time in order to perform stored xss
attack the malicious scripts should be
sent through the vulnerable input form
for example can be a comment field or a
review
field this way the appropriate script
will be saved in the database and
evaluated on the page load or
appropriate function
calling in a stored xss example the
script might have been submitted by an
input field to the web server which did
not perform a sufficient validation and
stores the script permanently in the
database the consequence of this might
be that the script is now being
delivered to all users visiting the web
application and for example able to gain
access to the user session
cookies in this attack the script is
permanently St in the web app the users
visiting the app after the information
retrieve the script the malicious code
then exploits the flaws in the web
application and the script and the
attack is visible on the server side or
to the app owner as
well the third variant is Dom based
cross-site scripting attacks this type
of attack occurs when the Dom
environment is being changed but the
client side code does not change when
the Dom environment is being modified in
the victim's browser the client side
code executes differently in order to
get a better understanding of how xss
Dom attack is being perform Let Us
analyze the following example if there
is a website called texting.com we know
default is a parameter therefore in
order to perform xss Dom attack we
should send a script as
parameters a Dom based xss attack may be
successfully executed even when the
server does not embed any malicious code
into the web page by using a flaw in the
JavaScript executed in the browser for
example if the client side JavaScript
modifies the Dom tree of the web page it
can be based on an input field or the
get parameter without validating the
input this allows the malicious code to
be
executed the malicious code the exploits
flaws in the browser on the user site
and the script and the attack is not
necessarily visible on the server side
or to the app
owner by now it is clear that cross-side
scripting attacks are difficult to
detect and even tougher to fight against
there are however plenty of fears one
can Safeguard against such attacks let's
go through some of these preventive
measures like mentioned earlier excess
attacks are sometimes difficult to
detect however this can be changed if
you get some external help a way to
prevent excesses attacks is using
automated testing tools like crash test
secur security suit or AC unetic
security
suit still manual testing is highly
timec consuming and costly and therefore
not possible to be done for every
iteration of your web
application consequently your code
shouldn't be untested before any release
using automated security you can scan
your web application for cross-side
scripting and other critical
vulnerabilities before every release
this way you can ensure that your web
application live version is still
secured whenever you alter or ADD a
feature input fields are the most common
point of entry for xss attack script
therefore you should always screen and
validate any information input into data
fields this is particularly important if
the data will be included as HTML output
this can be used to protect against
reflected exsis
attacks validation should occur on both
the client side and server site as an
added precaution this helps validating
the data before it's being sent to the
servers and can also protect against
persistent xss scripts this can be
accomplished using JavaScript xss
attacks only appear if any user input is
being displayed on the web page
therefore try to avoid displaying any
untrusted user input if possible if you
need to display user data restrict the
places where the user input might appear
any input displayed inside a JavaScript
tag or a URL shown on the site is much
more likely to be exploited than the
input that appears inside a division or
a span element inside the HTML body
protecting against accss vulnerabilities
typically requires properly escaping
user provided data that is placed on the
page rather than trying to determine if
the data is user provided and could be
compromised we should always play it
safe and Escape data whether it is user
provided or not unfortunately because
there are many different rules for
escaping you still must choose the
proper type of escaping before settling
on a final code
encoding should be applied directly
before user controllable data is written
to a page because the context you're
writing into determines what kind of
encoding you need to use for example
values inside a JavaScript string
require a different type of escaping to
those in an HTML context sometimes
you'll need to apply multiple layers of
encoding in the correct order for
example to safely embed user input
inside an event handler you need to deal
with both Javas script context and the
HTML context so you need to First
Unicode escape the input and then HTML
encoded content security policy or CSP
is a computer security standard
introduced to prevent cross-side
scripting click checking and other code
injection attacks resulting from the
execution of malicious content in The
Trusted web page context it is a
candidate recommendations of the w3c
working group on web application
security it's widely supported by modern
web browsers and provides a standard
method for website owners to declare
approved origins of content that browser
should be allowed to load on that
website HTTP only is an additional flag
included in a set cookie HTTP response
header using the HTTP only flag when
generating a cookie helps mitigate the
risk of client side script accessing the
protected cookie that is if the browser
supports it if the HTTP only flag is
included in the http response header the
cookie cannot be accessed through a
client side script again this is if the
browser supports this flag as a result
even if a cross-side scripting flaw
exists and a user accidentally accesses
a link that exploits this flaw the
browser will not reveal the cookie to a
third party if a browser does not
support HTTP only and a website attempts
to set an HTTP only cookie the HTTP only
flag will be ignored brows the browser
thus creating a traditional script
accessible cookie as a result the cookie
becomes vulnerable to theft of
modification by any malicious script
next on our docket is a live
demonstration where we solve a set of
cross-side scripting problems starting
from the basic level to the topmost
level six we're going to start at level
one in this web application it
demonstrates the common cause of cross
side scripting where user input is
directly included in the page without
proper
escaping if we interact with a
vulnerable application window here and
find a way to make it execute JavaScript
of our choosing we can take actions
inside the vulnerable window or directly
edit its URL bar this task needs only
basic knowledge let's see why the most
primitive injections work here right
away let's do a simple query and inspect
the resulting HTML
page I'm going to use this
phrase with a single quote as a special
character we can now inspect the HTML
page we can see here in this
line the special character single code
appears in the result over
here the provided query text is placed
directly in a b tag as in a body element
we need to perform a reflected xss into
the web application because they are
non-persistent xss attacks and the
payload should be included in the URL to
perform successful
exploitation we can use any payload but
we're going to use the simple one to
perform an alert in this web application
it's simple and can be shown
easily just going to write the script
over
here
I'm going to press
search as you can see we have
successfully launched our first
cross-site scripting attack we can see
an alert box pop up with the necessary
message and a similar process can be
used to steal browser cookies and
passwords albe it with different
commands now we have the option to move
to level
two in this web application it shows
that how easily xss bugs can be
introduced in complex chat
applications chat app conversations are
stored in a database and retrieved when
a user wants to see the conversation
therefore if a malicious user injects
some JavaScript code all visitors will
be infected this kind of cross site
scripting attack is more powerful and it
is more riskier than reflected crossed
scripting attacks and that's why is
known as stored
xss I posted my
query with a special character of a
single quote and this is what I
get whatever I typed in simply appeared
on the page right after I click on share
status let's see the
source
you can see here the text I posted seems
directly put inside a block code tag so
even a simple script tag we used in
level one should work here but it will
not let us examine the code to
understand
why we're going to toggle the code of
here and check the index.html
file important
part is line
32 the generated HTML fragment which is
the HTML variable in the code is added
to the male HTML using the inner HTML
method so when the browser passing this
HTML fragment it will not execute any
script tag defined within that HTML
fragment HTML parser will not execute a
script tag when it passes htmls via this
method this is why the script tag like
we used in level one is not going to
work here our solution is to use events
events will execute the defined
JavaScript we're going to use an image
over
here
and when we press on share
status in the above injection we are
loading an image that doesn't exist
which causes to trigger an on error
event in on error event the it will
execute our alert method with that we
are able to beat level two and we can
now move up to the next level in our
challenge
as you can see clicking on any tab
causes the tab number to be displayed in
the URL
fragment this hints that the value after
the hashtag controls the behavior of the
page that is it is an input variable to
confirm let's analyze the
code as you can see in line 43 inside
the event
handling the value provided after the
hash in the
URL is directly passed onto the chew tab
method no input validation is being
performed the value passed to the choose
tab method is directly injected into the
IMG tag in line
17 this is an unsafe assignment and it
is the vulnerable part of the code now
all we have to do now is to craft up
payload that would adjust the IMG tag to
execute our JavaScript remember the
script tag from level one would not work
here since the variable HTML is used to
add the Dom dynamically hence the events
are ases here once again I will choose
to use the existing IMG tag and change
the source to something that doesn't
exist hence forcing it to fall into to
execute an on error even which I will
pass the
URL
once we visit that URL we can see that
our Java popup has opened up here with
the same message of xss level 3 has been
completed with this we can now move on
to level four which is going to present
a different kind of
attack in this application there is a
timer on the page that means whatever
numbers we put in the Box countdown
starts and then when it finishes the
application alerts that the countdown is
finished and we can see the time is a
popup appearing over here and this
resets the timer again now it is obvious
that the value entered in the text box
is transferred to the server over the
timer parameter in the
URL let us examine the code to see how
the timer parameter is being
handled we're going to visit timer. HTML
over
here and we're going to check over here
in line
21 the start timer method is being
called in the onload event however the
timer parameter is being directly passed
to the start timer method we need to
perform a popup Alert in the web
application which escapes the content of
the function start timer without
breaking the JavaScript code the
parameter value is directly added to the
start timer method without any filtering
what we can try to do here is to inject
an alert function to be ex executed
inside the on loone event along with the
start timer
method we're going to remove this
argument and put our script over
here now when me press on create
timer and we have a popup with xss level
complete we can now move on to level
five in this web application this
application xss is different cuz this
challenge description says cross-side
scripting isn't just about correctly
escaping
data sometimes attackers can do bad
things even without injecting new
elements into the Dom it's kind of open
redirect cuz the attack payload is
executed as a result of modifying the
Dom environment in the victim's browser
this environment is used by the original
client side script so that the client
side code runs in an unexpected manner
the vulnerability can be easily detected
if the next Link in the signup page is
inspected the href attribute value of
next link is confirm which is exactly
the value of the next URL query
parameter as you can see over here this
means using the next query parameter can
be used to inject a JavaScript code to
the href attribute of the next link the
following is the best way to do it as
soon as the user clicks on the link the
script will be
triggered
going to press anything random and now
that we click next we can see the xss
level 5 that we had provided in the URL
as a parameter to the next
variable since the value of next
provided appears on a popup we can
consider the attack a success and move
on to the final level
six in this sub application it shows
some of the external Javascript is
received if you analyze the URL you can
see that the script is loaded already
the vulnerability lies within how the
code handles the value after the
hashtag if you check on line 45 the
value right after the hashtag is taken
as the gadget name and then in line
48 the value is directly passed on to
the include Gadget method and the
include Gadget method that we can see
over
here you can see in line
18 a script tag is created and the URL
Gadget name parameter value is directly
used as the source attribute of the
script tag in line
28 this means we can completely control
the source attribute of the script tag
that is being
created that is with this vulnerability
we can inject our own Javascript file
into the code we can inject a URL of our
own hosted JavaScript into the web
application's URL after the hashtag and
the URL should not be using https but
anything like that to bypass the regular
expression for security
checking going to remove the pre-stored
URL
and we're going to load our own
Javascript
file finally we have reached the end end
of our
challenge we completed six different
varieties of cross scripting attacks and
used different solutions for all of the
six questions with work from home being
the norm in today's era people spend
considerable amount of time on the
internet often without specific measures
to ensure a secure session apart from
individuals organizations worldwide that
host data and conduct business over the
internet are always at the risk of a DS
attack these these DS attacks are
getting more extreme with hackers
getting easy access to botet farms and
compromised devices as can be seen in
the graph three of the six strongest
Doos attacks were launched in 2021 with
the most extreme attack occurring just
last year in 2020 lately cyber criminals
have been actively seeking out new
services and protocols for amplifying
these DS attacks active involvement with
hacked machines and botet allow further
penetration into the consumer space
allowing much more elaborate attack
campaigns apart from General users
multinational corporations have also had
their fair share of problems GitHub a
platform for software developers was the
target of a DS attack in 2018 widely
suspected to be conducted by Chinese
authorities this attack went on for
about 20 minutes after which the systems
were brought into a stable condition it
was the strongest DS attack to date at
the time and made a lot of companies
reconsider the secur security practices
to combat such attacks even after years
of experimentation DS attacks are still
at large and can affect anyone in the
consumer and corporate space hey
everyone this is B from Simply learn and
welcome to this video on what is a Dos
attack let's learn more about what is a
Dos
attack a distributed denial of service
attack or DDOS is when an attacker or
attackers attempt to make it impossible
for a service to be delivered
this can be achieved by thating access
to virtually anything servers devices
Services networks applications and even
specific transactions within
applications in a Dos attack it's one
system that is sending the malicious
data or requests a DS attack comes from
multiple systems generally these attacks
work by Drowning a system with requests
for data this could be sending a web
server so many requests to serve a page
that it crashes under the demand or it
could be a database being hit with a
high volume of queries the result is
available internet bandwidth CPU and RAM
capacity become
overwhelmed the impact could range from
a minor annoyance from disrupted
services to experiencing entire websites
applications or even entire businesses
taking offline more often than not these
attacks are launched using machines in a
botnet a botnet is a network of devices
that can be triggered to send requests
from a remote Source often known as the
command and control center the bots in
the network attack a particular Target
thereby hiding the original perpetrator
of the DS campaign but how do these
devices come under a botn net and what
are the requests being made to the web
servers let's learn more about these and
how dos attack
work a Dos attack is a two-phase process
in the first phase a hacker creates a
bot net of devices simply put a vast
Network networ of computers are hacked
via malware ransomware or just simple
social engineering these devices become
a part of the botet which can be
triggered any time to start bombarding a
system or a server on the instruction of
the hacker that created the botn net the
devices in these networks are called
Bots or zombies in the second phase a
particular Target is selected for the
attack when the hacker finds the right
time to attack all the zombies in the
botnet network send these request the
target thereby taking up all the servers
available bandwidth these can be simple
ping requests or complex attacks like SN
flooding and UDP flooding the aim is to
overwhelm them with more traffic than
the server or the network can
accommodate the goal is to render the
website or service
inoperable there's a lot of wiggle room
when it comes to the type of DS attacker
hacker can go with depending on the
target's vulnerability we can choose one
of the three broad categories of of DS
attacks volume based attacks use massive
amounts of bogus traffic to overwhelm a
resource it can be a website or a server
they include icmp udap and spoofed
packet flood attacks the size of volume
based attack is measured in bits per
second these attacks focus on clogging
all the available bandwidth for the
server thereby cutting the supply short
several requests are sent to the server
all of which warrant a reply thereby not
allowing the target to cater to the
general legitimate
users next we have the protocol level
attacks these attacks are meant to
consume essential resources of the
target server they exhaust the load
balancers and firewalls which are meant
to protect the system against the dors
attacks these protocol attacks include
SN floods and Smurf DDOS among others
and the size is measured in packets per
second for example in an SSL handshake
server replies to the Hello message sent
by the hacker which will be the client
in this case but since the IP is poofed
and leads nowhere the server gets stuck
in an endless loop of sending the
acknowledgement without any end in
sight finally we have the application
Level attacks application layer attacks
are conducted by flooding applications
with maliciously crafted requests the
size of application layer attacks is
measured in request per second these are
relatively sophisticated attacks that
Target the application and operating
system level
vulnerabilities they prevent the
specific applications from delivering
necessary information to users and hog
the network bandid up to the point of a
system crash examples of such an attack
are HTTP flooding and bgp hijacking a
single device can request data from a
server using HTTP post or get without
any
issues however when the requisite botnet
is instructed to bombard the server with
thousands of requests the database
bandwidth gets jammed and it eventually
becomes unresponsive and
unusable but what about the reasons for
such an attack there are multiple lines
of thought as to why a hacker decides to
launch a Dos attack on unsuspecting
targets let's take a look at a few of
them the first option is to gain a
competitive Advantage many ds attacks
are conducted by hacking communities
against rival groups some organizations
hire such communities to stagger their
Rivals res sources at a network level to
gain an advantage in the playing field
since being a victim of a dets attack
indicates a lack of security the
reputation of such a company takes a
significant hit allowing the rivals to
cover up some
ground secondly some hackers launch
these DS attacks to hold multinational
corporations at Ransom the resources are
jammed and the only way to clear the way
is if the target company agrees to pay a
designated amount of money to the
hackers even a few minutes of inactivity
is detrimental to a company's reputation
in the global market and it can cause a
spiral effect both in terms of market
value and product security index most of
the time a compromise is reached and the
resources are freed after a
while DS attacks have also found use in
the political segment certain activists
tend to use DS attacks to voice their
opinion spreading the word online is
much faster than any local Rally or
Forum primarily political
these attacks also focus on online
communities ethical dilemas or even
protest against corporations let's take
a look at a few ways that companies and
individuals can protect themselves
against redos
attacks the company can employ load
balancers and firewalls to help protect
the data from such attacks load
balancers reroute the traffic from one
server to another in a DS attack this
reduces the single point of failure and
adds resiliency to the server data
a firewall blocks unwanted traffic into
a system and manages the number of
requests made at a definite rate it
checks for multiple attacks from a
single IP and occasional slowdowns to
detect a Dos attack in
action early detection of a Doos attack
goes a long way in recovering the data
lost in such an event once you've
detected the attack you will have to
find a way to respond for example you
will have to work on dropping the
malicious DS traffic before it reaches
your server so that it doesn't throttle
and exhaust your bandwidth here's where
you will filter the traffic so that only
legitimate traffic reaches the server by
intelligent routing you can break the
remaining traffic into manageable chunks
that can be handled by your cluster
resources the most important stage in
DOS mitigation is where you will look
for patterns of Dos attacks and use
those to analyze and strengthen your
mitigation techniques for example
blocking an IP that's repeatedly found
to be offending is a first
step Cloud providers like Amazon web
services and Microsoft Azure who offer
high levels of cyber security including
firewalls and threat monitoring software
can help protect your assets and network
from DS criminals the cloud also has
greater bandwidth than most private
networks so it is likely to fail if
under the pressure of increased DS
attacks additionally reputable Cloud
providers offer Network redundancy
duplicating copies of your data systems
and equipment so that if your service
becomes corrupted or unavailable due to
a Dos attack you can switch to a secure
access on backed up versions without
missing a beat one can also increase the
amount of bandwidth available to a host
server being targeted since DS attacks
fundamentally operate on the principle
of overwhelming systems with heavy
traffic simply provisioning extra
bandwidth to handle unexpected traffic
spikes can provide a measure of
protection this solution can prove
expensive as a lot of that bandwidth is
going to go unused most of the
time a Content delivery Network or a CDN
distributes your content and boost
performance by minimizing the distance
between your resources and end users it
stores the cached version of your
content in multiple locations and this
eventually mitigates dos attacks by
avoiding a single point of failure when
the attacker is trying to focus on a
single Target popular CDN include acomi
CDN Cloud flare AWS cloudfront
Etc let's start with our demo regarding
the effects of DS attacks on a system
for our demo we have a single device
that will attack a Target making it a
Dos attack of sorts once a bot net is
ready multiple devices can do the same
and eventually emulate a DS attack to do
so we will use the virtualization
software called VMware with an instance
of parad security operating system
running for a Target machine we will be
running another VMR instance of a
standard Linux distribution known as
Linux light in a Target device we can
use wire shark to determine when the
attack begins and see the effects of the
attack
accordingly this is Linux light which is
a target machine and this is parad
security which is used by the hacker
when trying to launch a DS attack this
is just one of the dros that can be
used to Launch the attack we must first
find the IP address of our
Target so to find the IP address we open
the
terminal we use the command if
config and here we can find the IP
address now remember we're launching
this attack in VMware now the both the
instances of parro security and Linux
light are being run on my local network
so the address that you can see here is
192.168
72129 which is a private address this IP
cannot be accessed from outside the
network basically anyone who is not
connected to my Wi-Fi when launching
attacks with public servers or public
addresses it will have a public IP
address that does not belong to the
subnet once we have the IP
address we can use a tool called hping
3 hping 3 is an open-source packet
generator and analyzer for the TCP IP
protocol to check what are the effects
of an attack we will be using wire shark
wire shark is a network traffic analyzer
we can see whatever traffic that is
passing through the Linux light drro is
being displayed over here with the IP
address the source IP and the
destination IP as to where the request
is being transferred to once we have the
Dos attack launched you can see the
results coming over here from The Source
IP which will be parent security Now to
launch the hping 3 command we need to
give pseudo access to the console which
is the root
access now we have the root access for
the console the hping 3 command will
have a few AR ments to go with it which
are as you can see on the
screen minus s and a
flood a hyphen
V hyphen p80 and the IP address of the
target which is 192 168
72129 in this command we have a few
arguments that such as the minus s which
specifies SN packets like in an SSL
handshake we have the SN request that
the client sends to the server to
initiate a connection The Hyphen flood
aims to ignore the repliers that the
server will send back to the client in
response to the SN packets here the
parent security OS is the client and
Linux slide being the
server minus v stands for verbosity as
in where we will see some output when
the requests are being sent the hyphen
p80 stands for Port 80 which we can
replace the port number if we want to
attack a different port and finally we
have the IP address of our
Target as of right now if we check wire
shock it is relatively clear and there
is no indication of a DS attack incoming
now once we launch the attack over
here we can see the requests coming in
from this IP which which is 192 168 72.1
128 till now even if the network is
responsive and so is Linux
light the requests keep on coming and we
can see the HTTP flooding has started in
flood
mode after a few seconds of this attack
continuing the server will start
shutting down now remember Linux light
is a drro that can focus on and that
serves as a back
end now remember Linux light is a drro
and such Linux DRS are served as backend
to many servers across the world for
example a few seconds have passed from
the attack now the system has become
completely irresponsive this has
happened due to the huge number of
requests that came from par
security you can see whatever I pressed
nothing is responded even the wire shock
has stopped C capturing new request
because the CPU usage right now is
completely 100% and at this point of
time anyone who is trying to request
some information from this Linux drro or
where this Linux drro is being used as a
backend for a server or a database
cannot access anything else the system
has completely stopped responding and
any request any legitimate request from
legitimate users will be
dropped once you stop the attack over
here it takes a bit of time to settle
down now remember it's still out of
control but eventually the traffic dies
down and the system regains its strength
it is relatively easy to gauge right now
the effect of a Dos attack now remember
this Linux light is just a VM instance
actual website servers and web databases
they have much more bandwidth and are
very secure and it is tough to break
into that is why we cannot use a single
machine to break into them that is where
a DS attack comes into play what we did
right now is a Dos attack as in a single
system is being used to penetrate a
Target server using a single request now
when a Dos attack multiple systems such
as multiple parro security instances or
multiple zombies or bots in a botnet
network can attack a Target server to
completely shut down the machine and
drop any legitimate request thereby
rendering the service and the target
completely unusable
and
inoperable as a final note we would like
to remind that this is for educational
purposes only and we do not endorse any
attacks on any domains only test this on
servers and networks that you have
permission to test on cyber security has
become one of the most rigid Industries
in the last decade while simultaneously
being the most challenged with every
aspect of corporate culture going online
and embracing cloud computing there is a
plethora of critical data data
circulating through the internet all
worth billions of dollars to the right
person increasing benefits require more
complex attacks and one of these attacks
is a Brute Force attack a brute force or
known as Brute Force cracking is the
Cyber attack equivalent of trying every
key on your key ring and eventually
finding the right one Brute Force
attacks are simple and reliable there is
no prior knowledge needed about the
victim to start an attack most of the
systems falling prey to Brute Force
attacks are actually well secured
attackers let a computer do the work
that is trying different combinations of
usernames and passwords until they find
a one that works due to this repeated
trial and error format the strength of
password matters a great dral although
with enough time and resources brute
force will break a system since they run
multiple combinations until they find
the right passcode hey everyone this is
B from Simply learn and welcome to this
video on what is a Brute Force attack
let's begin with learning about Brute
Force attacks in
detail a Brute Force attack also known
as an exhaustive search is a
cryptographic hack that relies on
guessing possible combinations of
targeted password until the current
password is discovered it can be used to
break into online accounts encrypted
documents or even Network peripheral
devices the longer the password the more
combinations that will need to be tested
a Brute Force attack can be timec
consuming and difficult to perform if
methods such as data offc are used and
at times downright
impossible however if the password is
weak it could merely take seconds with
hardly any effort dictionary attacks are
an alternative to Brute Force attacks
where the attacker already has a list of
usernames and passwords that need to be
tested against the target it doesn't
need to create any other combinations on
its own dictionary attacks are much more
reliable than brot force in a real world
context but the usefulness depends
entirely on the strength of passwords
being used by by the general
population there is a three-step process
when it comes to brute forcing a system
let's learn about each of them in
detail in step one we have to settle on
a tool that we are going to use for
brute forcing there are some popular
names on the market like
hashcat Hydra and John the Ripper while
each of them has its own strength and
weaknesses each of them perform well
with the right configuration all of
these tools come pre-installed with
certain Linux distributions that cater
to penetration testers and cyber
security analysts like K Linux and parro
security after deciding what tool to use
we can start generating combinations of
alpha numeric variables whose only
limitation is the number of characters
for example while using Hydra a single
six-digit password will create 900,000
passwords with only digits involved add
alphabets and symbols to that sample
space and that numbers grows
exponentially the popular tools allow
customizing this process let's say the
hacker is aware of the password being a
specific eight-digit word containing
only letters and symbols this will
substantially increase the chances of
being able to guess the right password
since we remove the time taken to
generate the longer ones we omit the
need for including digits in such
combinations these small tweaks go a
long way in organizing an efficient
Boost Force attack since running all the
combinations with no filters will
dramatically reduce the odds of finding
the right credentials in time in the
final step we run these combinations
against the file or service that is
being broken we can try and break into a
specific encrypted document a social
media account or even devices at home
that connect to the internet let's say
there is a Wi-Fi router the generated
passwords are then fed into the
connection one after the other it is a
long and arduous process but the work is
left to the computer other than someone
manually clicking and checking each of
these
passcodes any password that doesn't
unlock the router is discarded and The
Brute Force tool simply moves on to the
next one this keeps going on until we
find the right combination which unlocks
the
rout sometimes reaching the success
stage takes days and weeks which makes
it cumbersome for people with low
computing power at their disposal
however the ability to crack any system
in the world purely due to bad power
password habits is very appealing and
the general public tends to stick with
simple and easy to use
passwords now that we have a fair idea
about how Brute Force Works let's see if
we can answer this question we learned
about how complex passwords are tougher
to crack by Brute Force among the ones
listed on the screens which one do you
believe will take the longest to be
broken when using Brute Force tools
leave your answers in the comment
section and we will get back to you with
the correct option next week
let's move on to the harmful effects of
getting a system compromised due to
Brute Force
attacks a hack laptop or mobile can have
social media accounts logged in giving
the hackers free access to the victim's
connections it has been reported on
multiple occasions where compromised
Facebook accounts are sending malicious
links and attachments to people on their
friends
list one of the significant reasons for
hacking malware infusion is best done
when spread from multiple devices
similar to Distributing spam this
reduces the chance of circling back the
source to a single device which belongs
to the hacker once brute forced A system
can spread malware via email attachments
sharing links file upload via FTP
Etc personal information such as credit
card data usage habits private images
and videos are all stored in our systems
be it in plane format or root folders a
compromise laptop means easy access to
these information that can be further
used to impersonate the victim regarding
Bank verification among other
things once a system is hacked it can
also be used as a mail server that
distributes spam across lists of victims
since the hack machines all have
different IP addresses and Mac addresses
it becomes challenging to trace the spam
back to the original hacker with so many
harmful implications arising from a boot
Force attack it's imperative that the
general public must be protected against
such let's learn about some of the ways
we can prevent ourselves from becoming a
victim of Brute Force
attacks using passwords consisting of
alphabets letters and numbers have a
much higher chance of withstanding buil
Force attacks thanks to the sheer number
of combinations they can produce the
longer the password the less likely it
is that a hacker will devote the time
and resources to brute force them having
alpha numeric passwords also allows the
the user to keep different passwords for
different websites this is to ensure
that if a single account or password is
compromised due to a breach or a hack
the rest of the accounts are isolated
from the
incident two- Factor authentication
involves receiving a one-time password
on a trusted device before a new login
is allowed this OTB can be obtained
either via email SMS or specific tofa
applications like Ai and Aegis email and
SMS based otps are considered relatively
less secure nowadays due to the ease
with which SIM cards can be duplicated
and mailboxes can be hacked applications
that are specifically made for tofa
course are much more reliable and
secure captur are used to stop Bots from
running through web pages precisely to
prevent brute forcing through their
website since Brute Force tools are
automated forcing the hacker to solve
capture for every iteration of a
password manually is very challenging
the capture system can filter out these
automated Bots that keep refreshing the
page with different credentials thereby
reducing the chances of BR Force
considerably a definite rule that locks
the account being hacked for 30 minutes
after a specific number of attempts is a
good way to prevent Brute Force attempts
many websites lock account for 30
minutes after three failed password
attempts to secure the account against
any such attack on an additional note
some websites also send an email in
instructing the user that there have
been three insecure attempts to log into
the
website let's look at a demonstration of
how Brute Force attacks work in a real
world situation the world has gone
Wireless with Wii taking the re in every
household it's natural that the security
will always be up for debate to further
tou the security index and understand
Brute Force attacks we will attempt to
break into the password of a Wi-Fi
router for that to happen we first need
to capture a handshake file which is a
connection file from the Wi-Fi router to
a connecting device like a mobile or a
laptop the operating system used for
this process is parot security a Linux
distribution that is catered to
penetration testers all the tools being
used in this demo can easily be found
pre-installed in this operating system
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scaleup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
to start our demo we're going to use a
tool called airgeddon which is made to
hack into wireless network
specifically at this point it's going to
check for all the necessary scripts that
are installed in the
system to crack into a Wi-Fi and to
capture the handshake file we're going
to need an external network card the
significance of of the external network
card is a managed mode and a monitor
mode for now the wx1 named card is my
external network adapter which I'm going
to select to be able to capture data
over the air we're going to need to put
it in monitor mode as you can see above
it's written it is in managed mode right
now so we're going to select option two
which is to put the interface in monitor
mode and it name is now dou land Z
monitor the monitor mode is necessary to
capture data over the air that is the
necessary reason why we need an external
card since a lot of inbuilt cards that
come with the laptops and the systems
they cannot have a monitor mode
installed once we select the mode we can
go into the fifth which is the handshake
tools
menu in the first step we have to
explore for targets and it is written
that monitor mode is necessary to select
a Target so let's explore for targets
and press
enter we have to let this run for about
60 seconds to get a fair idea about the
networks that are currently working in
this locality for example this ESS ID is
supposed to be the Wi-Fi name that we
see when connecting to a network ge24
recover me these are all the names that
we see on our mobile when trying to
search for the Wi-Fi this BSS ID is
supposed to be an identifier somewhat
like a MAC address that identifies this
network from other devices the channels
features on one or two or there are some
many channels that the networks can
focus
on this here is supposed to be a client
that is connected to one such Network
for example the station that you can see
5626 this is supposed to be the MAC
address of the device that is connected
to a router this BSS ID is supposed to
be which wi-fi it is connected to for
example 5895 d8 is this one which is the
go24 router so we already know which
router has a device connected to it and
we can use our attack to capture this
handshake now that we it has already run
for 1 minute now that we press contrl
C it will be asked to select a Target
see it has already selected the number
five which is the ge24 router is the one
with clients so it is easy to run an
attack on and it is easy to capture a
handshake
for select Network 5 and we run a
capture
handshake it says we have a valid WPA
WPA2 Network Target selected and that
the script can
continue now to capture the handshake we
have a couple of attacks a do or a d or
air replay attack what this attack does
is kick the clients out of the network
in return when they try to reconnect to
the Wi-Fi as they configured that way
that when a client is disconnected it
tries to reconnect it immediately it
tries to capture a handshake file which
in turn contains the security key which
is necessary to initiate the
handshake for our demo let's go with the
second option that is the do air replay
attack select a timeout value let's say
we give it 60
seconds and we start the
script
we can see it capturing data from the
ge24 network and here we go we have the
WPA handshake
file once the handshake file is captured
can actually close this and here we go
congratulations in order to capturing a
handshake it has verified that a pmk ID
from the target network has successfully
been captured this is the file that is
already stored a do cap file for the
part path we can let's say we can keep
it in a
desktop okay we give the
path and the hand shap file is generated
we can already see a Target over here
same go24 router with the BSS
ID now if we return to its main
menu we already have the handshake file
captured with us now our job is to Brute
Force into that handshake capture file
the capture file is often encrypted with
the security key of the Wi-Fi network if
we know how to decrypt it we will
automatically get the security key so
let's go to the offline WPA wp2 decrypt
menu since we'll be cracking personal
networks we can go with option
one now to run the Brute Force tool we
have two options either we can go with
the air crack or we can go with the
hashcat let's go with air crack plus
crunch which which is a Brute Force
attack against a handshake file we can
go with option
two it can already detect the capture
file that we have
generated so we select
yes the BSS ID is the one which denotes
the go24 router so we're going to select
yes as well the minimum length of the
key for example it has already checked
that the minimum length of a Wi-Fi
security key which is a WPA2 psk key
will always be more than eight digits
and below 60 four digits so we have to
select something in between this range
so if we already know let's say that the
password is at least 10 digits we can go
with the minimum length as 10 and as a
rough guess let's say we put the maximum
length as
20 the character set that we going to
use for checking the password will
affect the time taken to Brute Force for
example if we already know that or we
have seen a user use the password while
connecting to the router as something
that has has only numbers and symbols
then we can choose accordingly let's say
if we go with only uppercase characters
and numeric
characters go with option
seven and it's going to start
decrypting so how aircrack is working
right here you can see this passphrase
over here the first five of six digits
are a it starts working its way from the
end from the last character it keeps
trying every single combination you can
see the last the fourth character from
the right side the D it'll eventually
turn to
e because it keeps checking up every
single character from the end this will
keep going on until all the single
characters are tested and every single
combination is tried out since the
handshake file is encrypted using the
security key that is the WPA2 key of the
router whichever past phrase is able to
decrypt the handshake key completely
will be the key of the Wi-Fi router this
is the way we can Brute Force into Wi-Fi
routers anywhere in the world cyber
attacks are frequently making headlines
in today's digital environment at any
time everyone who uses a computer could
become a victim of a Cyber attack there
are various sorts of cyber attacks
ranging from fishing to password attacks
in this video we'll look into one such
attack that is known as botnet but
before we begin if you love watching
Tech videos subscribe to our Channel and
hit the Bell icon never to miss an
update to begin with let's take a look
at some of the famous botet attacks the
first one is Mirai botnet which is a
malicious program designed to attack
vulnerable iot devices and infect them
to form a network of bots that on
command perform basic and medium level
denial of service attacks then we have
the zoos bot is specifically designed
for attacking a system for Bank related
information and data now let's see what
exactly a bot net
is botnet refers to a network of
hijacked interconnected devices that are
installed with malicious codes known as
malware each of these infected devices
are known as Bots and the hijack
criminal known as bot harder remotely
controls them the Bots are used to
automate large scale attacks including
Data Theft server failure malare
propagation and denial of service
attacks now that we know what exactly a
bot net is let's dive deeper into
learning how botnet works during the
preparation of a botnet network the
first step involves preparing the bot
net Army after that the connection
between the bot net Army and the control
server established and the end the
launching of the attack is done by the B
Herer let's understand through a
illustration
firstly we have a bot Herer that
initiates the attack according to the
control server commands the devices that
are infected with the malware programs
and begins to attack the infected system
let's see some details regarding the
preparation of the bot net
Army the first step is known as the
prepping the bot net Army the first step
is creating a botet is to infect as many
as connected devices as possible this
ensures that that there are enough Bots
to carry out the attack this way it
creates Bots either by exploiting the
security gaps in the software or
websites or using fishing attacks they
are often deployed through troan
horses for the next step we have
establishing the connection once it
hacks the device as per previous step it
infects it with the specific malware
that connects the device back to the
control Boton server a bot Herer uses
command program in to drive the bot's
actions and the last step is known as
launching the attack once infected a bot
allows access to atmin level operation
like Gathering and stealing of data
reading and rewriting the system data
monitoring user activities performing
denial of service attacks including
other cyber
crimes now let's take a look at the B
architecture the first type is known as
client server model the client server
model is a traditional model that
operates with the help of a command and
control center server and communication
protocols like
IRC when the bot Herer issues a command
to the server it is then related to the
clients to perform malicious
actions then we have peer-to-peer model
here controlling the infected Bots
involves a peer-to-peer Network that
relies on a decentralized approach that
is the BS are topological interconnected
and and act as both C and C servers that
is the server and the client to the
hackers adopt this approach to avoid
detection and single point
failure in the end we will see some
points on some countermeasure against
bot net
attacks the first step is to have
updated drivers and system updates after
that we should avoid clicking random
popups or links that we often see on the
internet and lastly having certain ified
antivirus anti- spyware softwares and
firewall installed into a system will
protect against malware attack the
internet is an endless source of
information and data still in some cases
we come across some occurrences like
cyber attacks hacking force entry which
may affect a Time on the web hi everyone
and welcome to the simply La Channel
today we will discuss a topic that
secretly records our input data that is
known as key loggers but before we begin
if you like watching Tech videos
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an
update to understand the key logging
problem better let's take a look at an
example this is June she works in a
business firm where she manages the
company's data
regularly this is Jacob from the
information Department who is here to
inform her about some of the security
protocols during the briefing she
informed him about some of the problems
her system was facing with which
included slow reaction speed and unusual
internet
activity as Jacob heard about the
problems with the system he thinks of
the possibility what could be the reason
behind these problems a system was
facing
with the conclusion that he came across
was the key logging
issue unknown to the problem her system
was facing with she ask him about some
of the details regarding
it for today's topic we learned what
exactly key loggers are and how they
affect our system what are the harmful
effects that key logging can bring into
the system to begin with we learn what
exactly the key logging program
is as the name suggests key logger is a
malicious program or a tool that are
designed to record key strokes that are
typed during data input and record them
into a log file then the same program
secretly sends these log files to its
origin where they can be used for
malicious acts by the
hacker now that we know what the key
logging program is let's take a look how
they enter into the
system searching for a suitable driver
for a system can often lead to the
installation of the key logging program
into the system if we often visit
suspicious sites and uncertified
software are installed into our system
then if we use unknown links or visiting
unknown websites which come through
unknown addresses can also be a reason
behind the key logging issue entering
into the system and lastly there are
often cases where different popups that
we often see on social sites or
different media sites can lead to the
installation of key loging program into
our
system now that we know how the problem
gets into the system let's take a look
how to identify whether the system is
infected by the key logging
issue
the key logging issue can be identified
if there are often cases when a keyboard
lags behind the system the data that we
enter sometimes is stuck in between when
we type through the
input then there are cases when the
system freeze occurs unknowingly to what
exactly could be the reason behind them
and also there are delate reaction time
for different applications that run on
the system and lastly there are
different cases when we often see
suspicious internet activity on the
system that we don't know about this
could lead to the identification of a
problem into the
system now we'll take a look at
different types of key loggers that are
present on the net which can harm our
system
differently the first problem that key
loggers arouse is API based the most
common key logging case which uses apis
to keep a log of the type data and share
it to its origin for malicious purposes
each time we press a key the key logger
intercepts the signal and logs it then
we have form grabbing based key loggers
as the name suggests they are based key
loggers that store the form data that is
if we often use web forms or different
kinds of forms to enter different data
they can be recorded into the system by
the program and send it to its
origin then we have kernel based key
loggers these key loggers are installed
deeply into the operating system where
they can hide from different antivirus
if not checked properly and they record
the data that we type on the keyboard
and send it to its
origin and lastly we have Hardware Key
loggers these key loggers are present
directly into the hardware that is they
are embedded into system where the
record the data that we type on the
keyboard now let's take a look how
hackers differentiate different type of
recorded data and exploit
them when hackers receive information
about the target they might use it to
Blackmail the target which may affect
the personal life of the Target and also
blackmail them for different money
related
issues then in case of company data that
is recorded by the Kil logging program
can also affect the economic value of
the company in the market which may lead
to the downfall of the
company also in some cases the key
logging program can also log data about
military Secrets which may include
nuclear codes or security protocols
which are necessary to maintain the
security of a
country now let's take a look whether
mobile devices get infected with the key
loging issue or not
in the case of hand devices infection of
key loggers are low in comparison to the
computer systems as they use onscreen
keyboard or virtual
keyboard but in some cases we often see
different kindes of malicious programs
getting installed into the hand device
if we often visit different uncertified
websites or illegal websites or torrent
sites and also the device that is is
infected with a key logging issue or
different kind of malicious program can
often lead to the exploitation of data
that includes photos emails or important
files by the hacker or the Cyber
criminal that install the particular
malicious program into the
system now to prevent our system from
getting infected by the key loging
program let's take a look at different
points the first point includes using of
different antivirus softwares or tools
which can prevent the entering a
malicious program into the
system then keeping system security
protocols regularly updated is also a
good
habit and lastly using virtual keyboard
to input our sensitive data which may
include Bank details login details or
different passwords related to different
websites now that we have some
understanding about the topic of key
loggers let's take a look at the demo to
further increase the knowledge about the
topic
for the first step we have to download
some of the important libraries that are
required into the
system which
is this library now we'll run
it the system says the library is
already installed into the
system now let's take a look what
exactly modules are required from the
particular
Library from this Library we'll
import the keyboard module which will
help us to record the data that we type
on the
keyboard now from the same we'll also
import key
module and The Listener
module and
also the logging module which will help
us to record the data into a log
file for the next part we'll write a
piece of code that will allow us to save
the data that is recorded by the program
into a text file that will be named as
keor log text file along with the date
and time stamp let's take a
look now we'll provide it with the file
name that will be given
as key log do txt
file and also so the part where the
format of the data is
recorded put the brackets over here to
contain the file name now we'll write
the format in which
the data will be recorded into the log
file which will be given
as the format would be the message and
the time stamp which would be given
as along with the time stamp
as
percentage and ending it with the
bracket now for the next step we'll
design two of the functions that will be
used into the program that will be
termed as while press function and while
release function let's take a
look while press
function would be a function that will
come into play when the keyboard key has
been
pressed
is
and this would go for the format that we
designed in the above
line
and
logging the Press
key
info a string file to be
recorded into the lock file
now now we'll design a function that is
while
release that will come into play
when the Escape key has been pressed
that is the program will terminate
itself and the pr program will stop from
running and in the
end we require for the functioning of
the program to Loop these functions that
is while press and while release to
continue its
cycle that will be going for while press
and
on release will contain while
release
function
as listen
now and now this part would join the
different threads and store them into
the log file now that we have completed
the code for the program let's run
it we have to wait for a moment so the
program runs it
now to verify the program let's open
notepad and on the notepad we'll
write
hello
world which will be the basic whether
the program is working or not let's take
a
look and we'll go for the main page on
Jupiter notebook and refresh the page go
to the
bottom over here we see the key log text
that is a text file that we created
let's open
it and over here we have the data that
is created as we started with Note then
this is the hello world part that we
created just
now which shows that the program we
created is working properly now that we
have reached the end of the module let's
take a look at the summary firstly we
learn what exactly key loggers are then
we understood what different modes are
present how the system get infected with
the key loging problem then we learned
how to detect take the problem into our
system then we learn what different
types of key loggers are present on the
net we also understood how hackers use
the recorded data from the program and
we also learn whether mobile devices get
infected with the key logging problem or
not and lastly we understood what
different points can be taken to prevent
the entering of the key logging problem
into the system before we learn about
the Pegasus platform let us understand
what spyware is and it's working spyware
is a category of malware that can gather
information regarding a user or a device
straight from the host machine it is
mostly spread by malicious links via
email or chat applications when a link
with the malware is received clicking on
this link will activate the spyware
which allows the hacker to spy on all
our user information with some spy
systems even clicking on the link isn't
necessary to trigger the malicious
payload this can ultimately cause
security complications and further loss
of privacy one such spyware system that
is making the rounds in the tech
industry today is Pegasus the Pegasus is
a spyware system developed by an Israel
company known as the NSO group it runs
on mainly mobile devices spanning across
the major operating systems like the
Apple's IOS on iPhone and the standard
Android versions this is not a newly
developed platform since Pegasus has
existed since as early as 2016 a highly
intricate spy program that can track
user location read text messages scan
through mobile files access device
camera and microphone to record voice
and video Pegasus has all the tools
necessary to enforce surveillance for
any client that wishes to buy its
services initially the NSO group had
designed the software to be used against
terrorist factions of the world with
more and more encrypted communication
channels coming to the Forefront Pegasus
was designed to maintain control over
the data transmission that can be a
threat to National Security
unfortunately the people who bought the
the software had complete control over
who how and up to what level they can
put surveillance limits on eventually
the primary clients became Sovereign
Nations spying on Public Information
that is supposed to stay private became
really easy with this service multiple
devices can be affect With the same spy
system to create a network information
this network keeps feeding data to the
host to understand how a network can be
created let's know how a mobile device
can be affected by Pegasus we all
communicate with friends and family over
instant messaging applications and email
in some instances if you check your
inbox on a regular basis you must have
noticed that we received some spam
emails that the mail providers like
Gmail and Yahoo can just filter into the
spam folder some of these messages
bypass this filter and make their way
into a person's inbox they look like
generic emails which are supposed to be
safe the Pegasus pyware targets such
occurrences by passing malicious
messages and links which which install
the necessary Spy software on the user's
mobile device be it Android or an iPhone
this isn't unique to the email ecosystem
since it's equally likely to be targeted
by SMS text WhatsApp Instagram or even
the most secure messaging apps like
signal and threa once the malicious
links are clicked a spyware package is
downloaded and installed on the device
after the Spy is successfully installed
the perpetrator who sent the payload to
the victim can monitor everything the
user does Pegasus can collect private
emails passwords images videos and every
other piece of information that passes
to the device Network all this data is
transmitted back to the central server
where the primary spying organization
can monitor the activities at a granular
level this is not even surface level
since complex py software like Pegasus
can access the root files on a mobiles
these root files hold information that
is crucial to the working of the Android
and iOS operating in systems leaking
such private information is a massive
blow to the security and the privacy of
an individual the information that may
seem trivial like the name of your Wi-Fi
connection or the last time you ordered
an item from Amazon are indeed all
valuable information this exploitation
is primarily possible due to the zero
day vulnerabilities known as bugs in the
software development process the zero
day bugs are the ones that have just
been discovered by some independent
security company or a researcher once
they are found reporting these
vulnerabilities to the developer of the
platform which would be either Google
for Android or Apple for iOS is the
right thing to do however many such
critical bugs make their way onto the
dark web where hackers can use them to
create exploits these exploits are then
sent to innocent users with a link or a
message like we had discussed before
Pegasus was able to affect the latest
devices with the all the security
patches installed but some bugs are not
reported to the developer ERS or just
cannot be fixed without breaking some
core functionality these become the
Gateway for spyware to enter into the
system you can never be 100% safe but
you sure can give it all in protecting
yourself the one thing where Pegasus
stands out is a zero click action
feature usually in spam emails the
malicious code is activated when the
user clicks the malware link a user
doesn't need to click the link in the
new version of the Pegasus and a few
other spyware programs once the message
arrives in the inbox of WhatsApp Gmail
or any other chat applications the
spyware gets activated and everything
can be recorded and sent back to the
central server the primary issue with
being affected by spyware as a victim is
detection unlike Crypt Miners and
Trojans spying Services usually do not
demand many system resources which makes
them tough to detect after they have
been activated since many devices slow
down after a couple of years any kind of
Performance Set due to such spyware is
often often attributed to poor software
longivity by the users they do not check
meticulously for any other causes that
is causing the Slowdown when left
unchecked these devices can capture
voice and video from the mobile sensors
while keeping the owner in the dark
let's take a moment to check if you are
well aware of the causes of such attacks
how do users fall pre to such spyware
programs a by installing untested
software B by clicking on the third
party links from email and messages C by
not keeping the apps and phones updated
or D all of the above let us know your
answers in the comment section below and
we will rev the correct answer next week
but what about the unaffected devices
the vulnerable ones while we cannot be
certain of our security there are a few
things we can do to boost our device be
it against Pegasus or the next big spy
on the market let's say we are safe now
and we have the time to take the
necessary steps to prevent a spyware
attack what are the things we can go for
a primary goal must always be to keep
our apps and the operating system
updated the latest security patches the
vulnerabilities that the exploits Target
are often discovered by developers from
Google and apple which send the security
patches quickly this can be done for
individual apps as well so keeping them
updated is of utmost importance while
the most secure devices have fallen pre
to Pegasus as well a security patch from
developers may help in minimizing the
damage at a later stage or maybe negate
the entire spyware platform alog
together another big factor is the
spread of malware is the trend of
sideloading Android applications using
APK files downloading such apps from a
third party website have no security
checks involved and are mostly
responsible for adware and spyware
invasions on user devices avoiding the
side loading of apps would be a major
step in protecting yourself we often
receive spam emails or texts from people
we may not know on social medias they
are accompanied need with links that
allow malware to creep into our device
we should try to follow the trusted
websites and not click on any links that
redirect us to unknown domains spy is a
controversial segment in governance
while the ramifications are pretty
extreme in theory it severely impacts
user privacy against authoritarian
regimes sufficient resources and a
contingent plan can alter the false ve
of democracy alog together even if our
daily life is rather simplistic we must
understand that private is not about
what we have to hide instead it portrays
the things we have to protect it stands
for everything we have to share with the
outside world both theorically and
literally hey everyone today we look at
the hack which took the World by storm
and affected multiple governments and
corporations the solar winds attack the
global statistics indicate that upward
of 18,000 customers have been affected
potentially needing billions to recover
the losses incurred before we have a
look at this hack Make sure to subscribe
to our Channel and and hit the
notification Bell to never miss an
update from Simply learn the date is
December 8th 2020 fire a global leader
in company specializing in cyber
security released a blog post that
caught the attention of the entire it
Community a software known as Orion
which was developed by solar wind
Incorporated had become a victim of a
remote access Trojan or a rat the breach
was estimated to be running since the
spring of 2020 and went virtually
unnoticed for months the review sent the
developers of the Orion software into a
frenzy as they quickly released a couple
of hot fixes for their platform in order
to mitigate this threat and prevent
further damage but how did this come
into existence we first need to
understand the platform which was
responsible for this preach soloin a
software company based in Texas United
States had developed a management
platform known as Orion Hing to
corporations and governments worldwide
oryan was responsible for the monitoring
and management of it Administration this
included managing the client servers
virtualization components and even the
organization Network infrastructure that
bought the platform solar wind claims
they have more than 300,000 clients
including US government agencies and
several Fortune 500 companies this
entire chain can be classified as a
supply chain attack in this variant of
cyber crime the hackers Target
relatively weaker links in an
organization's chain of control and
delivery these are preferbly services
rendered by a third party since there is
no Direct chice jurisdiction over it in
this case the Orion platform was the
primary target the culprit however was
software updates the update server for
solar Orion had a malicious version
attached with malware or a Trojan to be
precise this was made possible since the
code repository that handled the
software updates was breached once the
update server repository was compromised
the source code of the applications
became open to modification and
malicious code found its way onto the
software the remote access troen was
attached to a potential update nicknamed
the Sunburst update this update gave
hackers backdoor access to any client
that uses the correct version on its
release many clients believed the update
to be legitimate since it came from the
right source and they had no reason to
believe otherwise American government
agencies were supposedly hit the hardest
as the list of victims included the US
Departments of Homeland Security
treasury and health several private
companies like Cisco Nvidia and Intel
were compromised according to a list
published by the cyber security firm
trusk most of the companies had issues
quick updates to fix these
vulnerabilities introduced by the
software while the actual perpetrators
have never been found it is believed
that this was an act of crossborder
corporate Espionage conducted by state
sponsored hackers either from Russia or
China before we move forward let's take
a recap of the things we learned what
category of malware was responsible for
the solar wind hack was it one a virus a
remote access tro
a spyware or a worm let us know your
answers in the comment section right
away and we will reveal the correct
answer in a week coming to possible
reparations the Biden government has
launched a full investigation on the
effects and the repercussions of this
breach there are a couple of things that
we as consumers must always tend to when
working our way through the worldwide
web using a password manager is highly
recommended which can generate secure
alpha numeric passwords you must also
use different passwords for different
account accounts thereby reducing the
chances of a single point of failure
should one of those accounts get
breached usage of two-factor
authentication applications is also
encouraged since it acts as a safety net
if hackers directly get a hold of our
credentials clicking on unknown links
transmitted via emails is also a strict
no as is installing applications from
unverified sources the solar winds hack
is estimated to cost the parent company
nearly $18 million as reparations making
it one if not the biggest hacks in
cyberspace history as recently as of
July 2021 the hackers accessed some us
attorneys Microsoft 365 email accounts
as part of the attack criminal
organizations like the FBI and CIA are
determined to figure out the culprits
responsible for this debacle however the
intricacy and the full extent of the
breach makes it a way more complicated
jum than it looks on
paper staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to no
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here